wir sind auf dem weg zu einem konzert in
minnesota
der finnische rapper marky haymo alias
sein mag gibt heute sein lang ersehntes
konzert im max mara center seine liebe
zum hiphop begann schon als teenager
ich konnte den rhythmus spüren
da war einfach stark berlin ende doch
falsch sein mag ist jede bewegung jeder
rein
doch wie bleibt meinem rhythmus wenn man
nicht hören kann
die antwort darauf ist der bass ist sehr
tief und laut genug sprit sein mag den
beat mit den füßen
außerdem ist er nicht alleine auf der
bühne ich arbeite mit brandon zusammen
wenn ich seine lippen lesen weiß ich wo
wir sind im song
er sieht was ich verformen was
funktioniert
oder als ihrer teilnahme beim
vorentscheid des eurovision song contest
erreicht sein mag ein breites publikum
und viele seiner fans sprechen überhaupt
gar keine gebärdensprache
gebärdensprache hat vier parameter an
konfiguration hand orientierung
bewegungs ausführung und wo ich die
bewegung mache ein hip hop zählt der
reim das gilt auch für gehörlose
so heißt es gelangweilt aber hier
bedeutet es ernsthaft so reimann
denn sein mag und der sänger brandon auf
der bühne stehen kommen alle auf ihre
kosten
die gehörlosen und hörenden sein mag ist
der erste taube musiker mit einem
vertrag bei einem major label heute gibt
die band konzerte auf allen fünf
kontinenten
wie hier in äthiopien lassen die musiker
keine gelegenheit aus ihrem publikum ein
paar wörter in gebärdensprache
beizubringen
sein erfolg gibt ihm die möglichkeit
sich öffentlich für die rechte von
behinderten einzusetzen
die ganze welt soll sehen wie ihr
sprecher
wir fordern gleichberechtigung in
gebärdensprache
ja ich brauche einen übersetzer aber
eine übersetzung ist sprache keine
prothese wenn du gebärdensprache
sprechen könntest bräuchte ich keinen
übersetzer oder bin ich also behindert
oder nur eine sprachliche minderheit
sein mag mehr zu sagen als so manch
anderer rapper er kämpft für die
anerkennung als zauberkünstler und die
gleichberechtigung von schätzungsweise
70 millionen gehörlosen menschen auf der
welt